i was out the other night this is a new
thing now when people
i was edit i was at a socially distanced
backyard in los angeles which we all
know is burning down with covered we all
know that
and they're it covet is real disclaimer
it's real it can be devastating it's
[ __ ] up several people i know
those are all true things and and
and as apparently everyone in los
angeles has coveted even if you don't
have any symptoms and you've if you've
tested negative recovery you still
probably have covered right that is the
message from the government
if you don't have symptoms and you've
tested negative uh you're not out of the
woods
so by the way that's fun for the anxiety
hopefully nobody has anxiety
one in three la residents have been
infected by coronavirus it's a new
estimate
it's a nielsen rating right we think
this amount of people are watching
jersey shore
we don't know but if you have anxiety
this has been great
how's in the last year been nicer
remember when we all cared about mental
health
all of a sudden that went out the window
when the media every other day is going
are you do you feel good guess what did
you test negative
guess what you got it [ __ ]
it's real and it sucks but here's the
other thing this is a little a message
for the people that have survived it
because
i've had enough i really have had enough
now with
i was in a yard yesterday two people in
the yard had had covert
they hijacked the entire
event which was not really an event it
was just a
hang they hijacked it to discuss
how they both beat coven how bad it was
and how no one in the history of the
world will ever
understand the struggles that they went
through
not aids not cancer not those
[ __ ] with als nobody will understand
how hard it is to be covered i go i
haven't had it i said i've been being
relatively careful
i said i got very sick in march i had
all of the symptoms
i tightness to the chest i had chills i
woke up in the middle of the night
i couldn't really leave the bed i was
exhausted i could make it from my bed to
my couch
maybe i lost smell i don't really know
but i know that taste was all [ __ ] up
i could barely eat it took me three and
a half weeks to get my
things back and then they look at you
and they go no
you didn't have it you would know if you
had it this doesn't even feel
organic it's a bio weapon that you do
battle with and they're literally
doing like cobra kind moves in the yard
about how covered they're like
you think you're good then it hits you
from the side and then you double over
and then you have to kick
and if it hits you again and i'm like
what and then i'm like well other people
get really sick
you know my friend's mother had
pancreatic cancer she fought that for 10
years and they're like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i had covered you don't
understand it's
a bio weapon they act like they defeated
the chinese military with this
you can't even get a word in edgewise
with these people you can't say that
other people get sick
people die of cancer is cancer not a
thing anymore
what about aids with these [ __ ]
people
lesions all over every how about ebola i
mean these
[ __ ] cons will go to africa people
bleeding out of their eyes there's
lepers on the thing and they go you
don't know about covid
i couldn't taste my hot dog you don't
know about
covert it's just a bioweapon ebola is
just one of those
cute diseases that comes from the nature
it's not a
weapon i beat a weapon so it just gets a
little
it gets a little frustrating
what is that it frosty frustrating is
doesn't it sound better as
frustrate i do like that it's quicker
this whole thing we know how bad covert
is we know how much it [ __ ] people up
i've had
friends tell me how how how bad
it has been for them both physically and
mentally i understand
that dan carney for example my opener's
had it is now
occasionally tired so i get
i get it i get it i don't know why i
haven't had it
they're saying people that smoke are
getting it less frequently that's true
this is wild man if if the only thing
that cured culverd was
butts cigarettes i mean what a [ __ ]
i'm finding that 45 people are less less
likely to be current smokers
hospitalized coveted patients were 45
less likely to become smokers the
science is not here on this
i'm not trying to peddle junk science
because then we're going to be kicked
off youtube
and everything else all i'm saying is
this these are curious findings we don't
know i don't know why i haven't gotten
it
i'm not trying to get it i'm not saying
that i'm super human or anything i don't
have any
i'm taking the vitamins that joe rogan
tells me to take but every now and then
he calls me and he goes you know what
cures covered freshly fallen snow and
maple syrup but i'm like i don't think
so
but i'll do it right because he's
healthier than me and i trust him so
it is what it is he gets info from
doctors and different types of people
and people that are kind of doctors and
kind of are doctors a little um and i
respect you so
anything tells me to do i listen to him
the point is i don't know why i haven't
gotten this but here's what i will tell
you
i know that it's really bad and vicious
when people get it in a bad and vicious
way
but is one of the symptoms that you have
to discuss it for seven months
afterwards is there any let up here
because truly when you bring up any
other disease
they look at you like you don't get it
and i'm like well what about als where
you get diagnosed and you literally
become a puddle and then die within two
years they go
think i'm not still no not a bio weapon
they go you don't get they go you don't
get it
this is made in a lab and i beat it
and then they tell you they're like this
is how i beat it i
sat in a room and i just went i'm gonna
beat it i'm gonna beat it
i'm gonna beat it and they're like you
don't even understand the what you go
through
the mental fitness you have to ha and
i'm like yeah okay
but again my friend's mother fought a
death sentence pancreatic cancer
for 10 years it's unheard of the woman
was out doing marches she was raising
money
there are people that overcome horrible
conditions
there are people born with horrible
conditions okay
okay so this idea that the only thing in
the world
that any of the the the mark of a man is
that he beat covert
the mark of a man the mark of a soldier
they're acting and i know it's bad
but the way that they're talking and
acting makes me feel so much
less sympathetic for them because it's
getting obnoxious
it's obnoxious to tell a group of people
that somehow they're less than
because they didn't beat what they're
calling a chinese bioweapon these are
the people by the way that have had it
they're like china tried to take hong
kong with this bio weapon
i beat it but it's tough again my
friend's mother has brain cancer she
doesn't know
she walks in a wall she can't see
anything she's losing her sight in one
eye
[Music]
this is like nothing it's ever been
i'm like okay but what about i just keep
throwing out diseases how about
leprosy lee schmannus go to the symptoms
of leprosy please
see if we can get the symptoms of
leprosy up can we get
leprosy please because this is the stuff
i was bringing up
growths around the skin thick stiff or
dry
skin ulcers on the sores of feet
swelling or lumps on the face or
earlobes
loss of eyebrows or eyelashes discolored
patches of skin
usually flat that may be numb or look
faded
you know that ain't fun
right yeah it's very painful yeah pain
areas in the joints
blisters loss of color rashes ulcers
redness reduced sensation of touch pins
and needles loss of temperature
sensation nerve injury or weight loss
how about alex get als up that's a walk
in the park
apparently because you're covered let's
get als up
muscle cramps tight and stiff muscles
slur to nasal speech
difficulty chewing or swallowing which
which
ends up no chewing or swallowing okay
literally what it does is it immobilizes
you oh
and it's insane how bad it is okay
difficulty swallowing drooling lack of
restraint mild cognitive impairment
severe constipation
unintentional weight loss shortness of
breath difficulty
raising your foot so you bring this up
to these people and they go
dude you don't even get it you don't
even
[ __ ] get it dude this is like lab
made it's something
else something different it's just
annoying it's just annoying and it's
gotta stop
i know it's bad but it's gotta stop
life is a pandora's box of
horror okay people have
all kinds of problems some people's
problems are greater than others
some people have to go through horrible
things
okay i understand that this can be an
insane life-changing event for people it
could be a horrible thing it could kill
them it could kill me
i've been open and honest about that but
what we don't want to do is
annoy people to death as well
by by pretending that you are the only
thing that matters and that the things
that you've gone through
are the only things that anyone should
ever take seriously
that everybody else in this country
that's suffering because we have an
opioid epidemic or because their jobs
have evaporated
or because they don't have health
insurance okay or that they
work all week for [ __ ] wages and nobody
cares about them
and they have to [ __ ] navigate this
world without any help from anybody
those people should all shut the [ __ ] up
because you had it
got sick that is not the way to to
interface with the world people do not
want to tolerate that
they just do not like that so what you
have to do is you have to have some
perspective
and see things with proportion and i
know this is a bad disease and i know
it's affected people
people have died families have been
ruined and i'm not making light of any
of that what i'm saying is please
if you've gotten through it confide in
some close friends about how tough it
was
but otherwise shut the [ __ ] up because
there are people that are dropping dead
every [ __ ] day that have diseases
that make this look like a walk in the
[ __ ] park
there's people that have brain tumors
that are like
you can't even [ __ ] operate
inoperable
brain tumors that destroy their entire
lives
people hear every day you got to get
your affairs in order
so let's just put a pin in it
for a minute when you're in a yard with
people and they're trying to relate to
you i'm trying to relate to you i'm
trying to go
yeah man i was a little sick at marshall
like no no no you know you know with all
due respect
with all due respect you don't
understand what this is
i fought the chinese i fought the
chinese in one
your your friend's mother with the
pancreatic cancer that's a walking let's
be honest that's a walk in the park
okay it's a walk in the park hey last
wheelchair can't move
stop stop
i had covered okay
i don't want to hear about your
hemorrhagic fever your ebola
blue